おはよう起きた起きた
こんにちははじめ社長ですだけで皆さん
たくさんチョコ準備しました
私事ではございますが実は最近チャンネル
登録者が1000万人を突破しました
ありがとうございますこれは完全に皆様の
お陰ですあのする僕が動画だすとかそう
いうのもあるんですけどもみなさんが
チャンネル登録ボタンを押してくれないと
こっちチャンネル登録1000万に行け
なかったので本当に皆さんにここから関西
しているんです
感謝しているね本当にありがとうござい
ますでチャンネル登録者数1000万に
行く時に僕ティッシュ配りと結構してるん
ですけどもそれとかでチャンネル登録して
くださった方も結構いらっしゃると思うの
でそのお返しに関する機物を止めたくて本
腕とヒットパットさんの新商品ハートフル
目あってめっちゃ可愛いチョコレートが
あるんですけどもどちらをとある場所で
奪っていきたいとおもいちょっと追いかけ
てみますねーかわいい
こんなんもらったら気になっちゃうて風船
にメッセージ書いてあるんですけども i
love you
こういう3角3種類のメッセージが書かれ
ていてちょっとした気持ちを伝えたいとき
にさりげなくカジュアルには立てる
チョコレートになっております
もうね今回は一定などのハートフルでや
一番好きしますので一番個配って皆さんに
感想を伝えていきたいと思いますでは
さっそく貼っていきましょう
いますつきましたここでさんネル登録して
もせなくても感想を伝えていきたいと思い
ますいつもその頃な対策万全な状態で人も
集まらないようにちょっとゲリラ的と言い
ますが全く押し出せなしでプレーをやって
いきたいとおもいます当然でも屋台も準備
していますここでちょっと変わって行き
たいと思いますよしまーしかし
セッティングしていこう
いやすごい量よなんてこれイベントに来て
いる人数より多いせたるティッシュみたい
でする店とそうですね
私からのチョコはもう本当にただの幸せを
まき火水上とかもなかった飾りたいですね
提灯ですからめちゃくちゃ中華ですね
[音楽]
男いやイェーガー
パーサーも naon 教化見えてみた
はい
に葉を図ったどう見ても通過料理屋さんな
んだろうのコツをつけます
愛というわけで屋台完成しましたもう粒
世界観がわからないと果たして本当にそこ
を上げる屋台なのかどうかも分かりづらい
んですけど皆さんに感謝を伝えていければ
いいなと思ってそこを配っていきます
よしつーわけで早速1万個を配っていき
ましょうちょっとこの風呂なんか的な問題
でて渡っているのがアレなのでもう完璧に
対策はされております別もちゃんともう
並べるようになってるんで僕が私ってより
とってもらうという形になりそうなんです
けどまぁこういうご時世なのでちょっと
仕方ないんですけどもそれでもちゃんと
感謝伝えていきたいと思いますよしいき
ます
[音楽]
これさー
おっことっ
そんな対策しっかり時すぎて出来づらいせ
てある
でも
ああああああ
そこどうぞぜひ持ってくださいただ社長
喋るん
本当にする
ありがとう
ありがとうございます
ありがとうありがとう
2人の大家故でしたすごいあんな小さい子
でも外れ冊を見てるんだって
すごいね何の動画みたいみんなに待ってる
ねほんとに教育委悪影響ある道があるから
な悪く育たないよ2
[音楽]
ええええええ
なんかばの末8敗だった
hono
デー
uh
多いとどうぞ
なんか感謝したい人とか言いません
感謝したいですね
俺はぜひば家族にロップってあげて
ください
事故で猫であげればなかった事が見えて
くるありがとうございます
雪は誰に感謝したいん俺さっきデータ41
笑われてはいるが
ちょっと一番やりすぎたかああ
どうぞ
[音楽]
アーサー入っていますあればいじめだけ
どうぞ4も載ってるんじゃねーよまで全く
見てません奪いに来ないでちゃんと伝え
たいと思いますます
秦こころもうすぐバレンタインシンガー
同社はおとうさんおとうちゃんということ
を投稿するございましたのは6秒経過皿を
のかグレーたら点火したカードだから
およびあってこれからを見てくださいはい
ありがとうございますありがとうござい
ます
def
どうだねっ是非みてくださいこれ
ni
[音楽]
hello
world
ああああああ
who ん
ありがとうございました
[音楽]
敗戦国場で終わりましたちょっと
すごいねでもなんかすごいを耐え
ありがとうやってですが気持ちがいい
頑張ります
[音楽]
me
宜しくお願いします
何個か23を送ってくださいねどうぞ味は
どれも一緒ないうーん
me
あるいはそれません
はぁはぁまぁ
天井のメバルのたを飲んだ前雅淑隆見て
そこへと変わったら右にアバせください
マネー
サバ系ってないもんなぁ
ございます
ます
2千石貼り終わりましたちょっとねぇ
ティッシュ配りの時とばけが違ってこの中
だから消毒とか手袋してもらったりして
いるので非常に回転率が遅いね時間の許す
限り頑張りたいと思います
朝ませんうわーこ12のこれーと猫山さん
てるか的なるほどでてくださいねリーダー
んぼぐらい版暖冬でいいきますよね
hers os た舞台化されていました
いい
[音楽]
いいですありがとう
23今までだったらイヤなのだろう本番
ok
よそぞ通りでねぇ
goo
[音楽]
ありがとう
ございますああああああ
タイムアップだけんすけちょっと全部配れ
なかったなぁができる見解の感謝は伝えれ
たような気がします俺もめっちゃリガ
ドッグ見えたしいろんな人にもありがとう
って言ってくれたんですけど楽しかった
です
こそ
歩い
おつかれさまでしたちょっとさすがにもう
1日外でちょっと変わってると寒かった
ですけど結局トータルで2900から3千
個ぐらいは組まれたのかなと思います何か
こういう故事戦なのでなかなかパーって
配れなかったのが残念だったんですけども
お客さんの方に感謝が伝えられて本当に
よかったです相手で今回みなさんに
プレゼントしたこちらのキットカットの
ハートフル米なんですけれどもちょっと
開けてみますね見てこの可愛らしいクマ型
のチョコレートなんですよね中でですね
サクサク食感のウエハースが入っており
まして甘さが控えめですけどそんな中全く
甘くないわけでもないいい感じだまさの
チョコレートとのバランスのとれたおいし
さがたまらなく美味しいです見た目が全く
新しい特別な形をしたスペシャルなキット
カットでございますさっきも言ったんです
けどもこのくんさんが持っているハート型
の風船には3種類のメッセージが書かれて
おりますのでちょっと恥ずかしいけれど
そこの君さりげなく伝えたい時にぜひ
ハートフルベア使ってみてはいかが
でしょうかそして皆さん今こういうご時世
なんてなかなかこうチョコレートとかもの
を人には山が難しい人っていらっしゃると
思うんですけどもそこのあなた素晴らしい
ものがございますバレンタインポストと
いうものがございましてどんなことかと
言いますとデジタル超でバーチャルチョコ
とメッセージお気軽に送り合えるスマート
フォン向けのサービスですっ昨日ちょっと
ご紹介します快適でこちらの画面が
バレンタインポストの画面ですはじめ社長
のポストチョコおねだりできますをしてみ
ましょうか頬に
はいこれで募金はおねだりした直後くれる
まで動きませんとこすると他の人が始めは
ちょっと欲しいんだってだかわかるって
いうやつです次は何だからチョコを送って
みようチョコをくれまし送ってみよう1人
から5年に贈るだちょっとあの僕
チョコチップパンで友達がいるのでこの人
に送ってみようと思いますギアすごい
ちょっとめっちゃも送れるんだ余ったから
あげる遅れるちょもこれで変更できると
いうわけですね送ると
今ベルトチョコをくれるという寒い前後の
ポストがそして今年のバレンタインポッド
何と私始め社長のオリジナルポイントが
ありますこれでもゲットする方法があるん
ですけどもこちらにありますキットカット
のハートフルベアをスマートフォンで月足
て肇社長ポストはゲットしを見て下さいか
も可愛いギブミーてくれるプレ発目社長
ポットですじゃあさっそくちょっと今
スキャンしてみようと思いますぐっ特別
クエスト
弾み社長ポストん
ここでスキャンできるんですよいきますよ
これキャンで出てくるすごいぞ
[音楽]
ん
動き好きだけど来ました来ましたはい
ギュッとしましたありがとうございます
こういう感じでハートフルベアの2部が
あれば簡単にゲットできるので皆さん是非
行ってみて下さい詳しくは動画の概要欄に
ありますので是非皆さんチェックしてみて
くださいというわけでみなさんもうすぐ
バレンタインでですね大好きな花の一いつ
も感じているあの人に想いを伝えてみては
いかがでしょうかじゃんっ
あっ
[音楽]
ハール
hel